[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we get to the mike shishway interview
as we uh sat down with him yesterday
after his press conference and here is
how it started
we welcome in the former duke head coach
mike shashefsky
and i love the fact that there's no
victory tour you end this now it's clean
you don't have to have everybody say
nice things about you give you gifts
along the way so coach you did it the
right way
and i applaud you yeah i like the thing
you said about victory tour because
that's what i would like it to be
uh no it's uh
it it's time but i wanted to coach
another year but then how do you do that
if you're not how do you recruit kids
that you're not going to coach next year
it's important i don't
think that's right and so i think this
is a good plan of succession
uh john scheier is ready and
uh let's have a we're gonna have a
hopefully a great year now and hopefully
that'll be
continued if you go back to when you
first started i think you were 33
when you got to duke so maybe a year
younger than
john is what do you what do you see in
john that
may remind you of yourself at a similar
age well
i think john is better prepared to be
the duke coach than i was
not to be a head coach at a college like
i was a head coach at a college
a great school at west point but i
wasn't
ready to be at this level uh
i had a learning curve on what it would
take
the recruiting and everything that in
order to compete in my neighborhood
john already knows that he uh you know
he's been my lead
guy for three years he's been on the
staff eight years so
for this job i think he's better he's
better prepared and he also understands
the current state of recruiting
the people that you have to have
relationships with that has changed over
the years
and he's he's done that he's very very
good at that
take us back to year two year three you
had 10 wins 11 wins
right were you nervous about keeping
your job
i wasn't nervous or a lot of people duke
fans that were nervous about
me keeping my job uh but thankfully not
my
my two bosses tom butters who believed
in me
and president sanford who
believed in me and we were a team
that doesn't happen as much nowadays
and there was a process of growth and
also dan it was a time where
there wasn't uh the turnover every year
in college basketball
so now you might be facing jordan for
three years
which we did or samson for four years
you weren't facing them for one year and
then they had to retool
so the uh the patients but also the
uh the savvy of my two bosses
and their belief in me you know
obviously it paid off
first time you woke up and said that
word retirement
you remember i haven't yeah i haven't
said the word retirement yet because i'm
gonna
i'll say that in the spring you know i
just said i'm not
i'm coaching this year and then that'll
be it
so i'm not retired right now now i'm
i'm an active participant
in the so in other words i'm not there
yet if i was there yet then i would
wouldn't do
a good job in being the coach this year
so i have to be in this moment but i has
to let people know
what my what the plan is then i'm going
to stop coaching
which lends itself to say coach k is
going to retire
i'm not trying to make this a play on
words but
it really is how you have to focus
on this if i'm already thinking
retirement then i should
you know i gotta i gotta think of being
passionate about coaching which i am
do you have any hobbies uh listening to
your show
yep uh well that's a full-time job
that's not a fun
hobby my family is trying to break me of
it and
i said no i gotta be loyal to this guy
he doesn't have many listeners
yes you're right yes yeah i don't want
to be
you and jim behind those the only two
only two listeners i got and
you know i could lose one of you and we
we do listen
uh no my hobbies are
uh have been my what i do you know i i
coaching has been my work my hobby but
uh my family i've been lucky all my
my daughters their husbands and my 10
grandkids live right behind me
and then i i'd really like to do a lot
out and
we have a big we have a lot of land and
beautiful and i just like to be outside
and
plant stuff cut it down figure it out
just to be outside who's the first
player you heard from
wow you know i don't i don't know that
i've heard from so many of them
maybe wojo maybe maybe wojo
he's one of the first ones did he slap
snyder i heard from quint snyder
yesterday during a playoff game
and uh and then i text them
i didn't get back to all my tests
attacks
you know we had a lot of them and uh so
i'm watching his game and i finally
looked at his text i said
holy crap i'm watching his game so i
text him i said
i'm watching your game hopefully you
won't read this during the game
and uh and then he you know he got back
afterwards
you said in your press conference that
you'd like to get a
team picture every player
yeah i don't think we can pull that off
can we coach
no we can't but to me that
you know it's it you know the guys
who've been in it for a long time
and hopefully the the guys who haven't
been in it for a long time
but the guys who've been in for a long
time recognize that and i'm not
i'm not the only one i'm one of many
that know that
it's about the relationships you develop
with your players
and during this time it uh it's
more difficult to develop those
deep-rooted relationships because you
don't have
as much time and it's a danger really in
our sport right now
with almost 1700 kids in the transfer
portal
that a big part of developing a
relationship
is going through a tough time
and where you'd go through a tough time
together a tough time of improvement or
understanding or
whatever and i'm not saying every kid
that transfers walks away from that
but a number of them would rather try
something different than
make that work and all i know is
the guys that i've coached where they
made it work
they've gotten better our relationship
is deep
and it goes on for forever so i worry
about that
dan in our game uh but
again the freedom of movement and all
that i'm all for it
i just wish we could take care of the
other thing too
two months ago roy williams announced
that he was retiring
what kind of impact did that have on you
uh
and any with your decision yeah well
ryan are actually really good friends
and a big thing is we we both understand
the magnitude of
of the re of the job that we we've had
he had
and now i still have and
what it means to a university what it
means to our sport
the demands of that job no other person
really understands that
unless they're in that and it's really
one of the reasons uh coach dean smith
and i developed
a very good relationship as i grew up
before i grew up in this game you know i
didn't understand him and was
at you know and then all of a sudden oh
now i get it and uh so i
you know it's it's there's going to be a
time for all of us i'm just glad that
roy picked the time that he feels
is best for him i'm trying to and
how about us being able to pick the time
uh
it's pretty good you know that
we're both of us are the lucky ones to
be able to do that
he's the current but sort of former
coach at duke he's
mike szyszewski uh will you miss games
more or practices more
uh uh just the practices the
uh the workouts the
times where guys can just be guys you
know uh obviously the excitement of a
game we
we didn't have any of that this year and
i'm anxious to get back to that
and i'll be all right without that i
think after this year
but uh i will always miss the the
development of relationships and
just the goofing around getting on
somebody when they
needed it praising them uh
you know what how many people in their
70s
are able to hang and develop a
relationship with
people 18 to 23 or a staff that's 33 to
40
you know which keeps them young and
vibrant you get energy
from them i'll miss that and i know that
that'll be somewhat of a void
when it happens you know where because
you do get energy
when you're with those youngsters did
you ever get to the point where you
enjoyed the wins
more than that feeling of losing like
could it could winning ever overshadow
that feeling of losing
well losing was lower than winning was
high
yeah i would say that no no question
and but i think if you talk
i would think most people who who've
been
fortunate enough to have a a number of
successes a lot of successes
would say the same thing you know that
they
you have to because you avoid that
you want to avoid that feeling it's not
just beating the other
uh team or the the opponent it's not
not wanting the position that you would
be in if you lose
uh now in saying that
the highs are pretty good too you know
like uh
when you win a national championship or
you know for me
winning olympics and world championships
have been in five of those
that was that was unbelievable
not to do that however the lowest moment
i've had
in coaching was with usa basketball when
we were learning and we lost in
206 to greece and tokyo and then we won
after that every game but uh and five
championships but so that low
was the lowest there's no question about
it like the lowest of
all of your losses including duke oh
did you let down the country is that
what you felt you went down
yeah i mean you're coaching the united
states team yeah
and you lose i mean you know
you you that uh
and thank goodness i was with
just an amazing guy and jerry colangelo
who said we're going to get this done
and
[Music]
then he believed in me and uh
believed in us and then it worked out
that we developed a really good culture
with
all those guys who you know made a lot
of sacrifices
in order to play finish this sentence if
christian laitner doesn't go to duke
i'm you may not be talking to me
christian lightner was
the best player you know the most
accomplished player here at duke i mean
he
maybe one of the top five players in
history of the ncaa
uh you know we're talking about
every year final four you know
national championships he was you can
only win six games
in the ncaa tournament when you win the
whole thing
in his four years he was 21 and two
it could be crazy i mean that those
things are
are are not and i'll tell you what
i've had the belief of many many of my
players
uh no one believed in in me and our
relationship more than christian
you know he was uh everyone can say
about what he
what what he was for me he was as good a
guy as i could have ever coached and as
great a competitor
as i have coached well shaq on tnt
the other night said that when he played
against christian the first time he said
he ate my lunch
like he said i had to reassess my game
because
that guy was not bigger than me stronger
than me more athletic than me
but he ate my lunch you remember that
meeting between those two well
he has uh selective memory and good
memory and i love shaq
but lightner did that twice
[Laughter]
and well i think shaq's one of the top
maybe 10 players in
ever but in college uh
and and we had a pretty good supporting
cast too
some hurley and grant hill helped him a
little a little bit
but uh those were you know uh
thank i appreciate it i love shaq and
that but
when you talk to him tell him there was
a game at duke and then again
did you recruit shaq no that was
you know he was in germany you know he
we didn't know about him you know dale
brown
that was so cool you know
like where did this guy come from and
there were no aau tournaments or
yeah you know like uh you didn't get a
scanner report from mannheim or
or berlin saying hey there's this guy a
really good guy out there
you know somehow uh he had the intel
and his dad was military so
you know they were lucky they were lucky
to get them indulge me in this you
brought it up before we've talked about
it but take me back to that moment where
you nearly took the lakers job
well uh it was at a time of
of uh i think people
if they're lucky enough they're able to
make
their success have they had enough in a
certain
period of time at a certain location do
they need to make
to do something else in their career and
i was 57
and you know i
the pros were appealing to me and then
kobe was appealing to me
because i i knew him as a youngster
and uh and the lakers their brand
was and uh so what i
and then the amount of money was
generational
and uh but i
i could not leave duke
and i mean we're making good money not
the money that they were talking about
but
uh i love duke i love college basketball
and uh ironically five months after
turning it down jerry colangelo offered
me the national team
even though you don't get paid for that
the ability to coach the pros was then
not just satisfied it was magnified not
be
uh i got a chance to coach more great
players than anybody
because of my my time at duke but also
my
more my 11 years uh coaching the us team
do i have to get you a gift well i
should have surprised me i thought there
would be one already i thought that was
the end
that's the only reason i did the damn
they said at the end
dan's going to surprise you with this
amazing gift
now you're asking me you've ruined it
well i
i thought you were you retired
we'll see now now i have a year let's
give me something to look forward to
in the spring you know when you buy a
wedding gift you don't have to get the
gift then
you have a year to get that wedding gift
for the couple
i got a year you know that my wife gets
the wedding gifts yeah
yeah so i did not know that i was
going to learn something usually when we
do interviews
it's kind of void of learning
opportunities yeah and
and today i got one unbelievable thank
you
i'm thinking of retiring after doing
this interview just
just to let you know i'm i'm going to
leave you with this
when you hear behind's voice do you
think it
sounds like a car trying to start in
cold weather
so if it's like
what do you think coach well i think
you're right
but i i love the sound of a car
starting in cold weather because i love
jim and he and i
but it's once it starts there's usually
a lot of wisdom
that's a lot of wisdom hey i didn't know
are you just you're going to retire and
be like a comedian or
no no no i'm going to join shire's staff
he's going to need all the help he can
get
he's going to need a shooting coach and
i'm right here nobody plays defense
just offense i can help him you
he no he's going to go after a hitting
coach
anybody can hire a shooting coach he's
going to go after someone who hits shots
oh make shots
make a maker because when they said you
know
i would always say that i was a a making
guard they'd say are you a shooting
guard and i go no i i'm a making guard
so i understand what you're saying coach
you separated yourself from the
magnitude
yes you've always found that down yes i
am
sometimes in good or sometimes and not
so good
thank you coach all right man nice being
on with you